Traductor: Silvina Katz
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Al cumplir los 20 años, dos astronautas
gemelas participan en un experimento.
Terra se quedará en la Tierra
y Stella se irá de viaje en un cohete.
El navío de Stella viajará a 86.6 %
a la velocidad de la luz
hasta llegar a una estrella
que está a 10 años luz,
y regresará a la Tierra
a la misma velocidad.
Al prepararse a partir,
las gemelas se preguntan
qué ocurrirá cuando se reencuentren.
Como un año luz es la distancia
exacta que viaja la luz en un año,
el viaje de Stella tardará 23 años.
Pero como las gemelas
estudiaron la relatividad especial
saben que no será tan sencillo.
En primer lugar, cuanto mayor es
la velocidad de un objeto en el espacio,
más lento parecerá en el tiempo
respecto a un observador que no se mueve.
Esta relación se puede calcular
usando el factor de Lorentz,
que queda definido por esta ecuación.
En segundo lugar, la longitud
de un objeto en movimiento
medida por un observador en reposo,
se contraerá según el mismo factor.
A 86.6 % de la velocidad de la luz,
el factor de Lorentz es 2,
lo cual significa que el tiempo pasará
dos veces más despacio en el cohete.
Queda claro que Stella no se dará cuenta
de que el tiempo va más despacio.
Sucede porque los procesos
de la nave basados en el tiempo
también irán más despacio:
los relojes y dispositivos eléctricos;
las actividades biológicas de Stella
como su tasa de envejecimiento
así como su propia percepción del tiempo.
Las únicas personas que pueden notar
que el tiempo del cohete en movimiento
pasa más despacio para Stella
serían los observadores en de un sistema
de referencia inercial o no acelerado,
como Terra, en la Tierra.
Por lo tanto, Terra concluye
que cuando se reencuentren en la Tierra,
ella será más vieja que Stella.
Esa es solo una manera de ver las cosas.
Como todo el movimiento es relativo,
Stella argumenta que sería igual de válido
decir que su cohete quedaría estático,
mientras que el resto del universo,
hasta Terra, se moverían a su alrededor.
En ese caso, el tiempo pasaría
dos veces más despacio que para Terra,
y al final Stella terminaría siendo
la gemela más vieja.
No pueden tener razón las dos
y ser las más viejas, ¿quién tiene razón?
A esta contradicción se la conoce como
la "Paradoja de los gemelos".
Pero no es una paradoja real,
es solo un ejemplo de como se puede
malentender la relatividad especial.
Para comprobar las teorías en tiempo real,
cada gemela acuerda enviarle
a la otra una ráfaga de luz
cada vez que pase un año para ellas.
A diferencia de otros objetos, la
velocidad de la luz es siempre constante
independientemente del sistema
de referencia del observador.
La ráfaga de luz enviada desde la Tierra
se mide a la misma velocidad
que la enviada desde el cohete,
ya sea esté de ida o de vuelta.
Así que cuando una de las gemelas
vea una ráfaga de luz,
medirá cuanto tardó la otra
en ver pasar año,
y cuanto tardó la luz
en llegar de una a la otra.
Podemos ver lo que pasa en este diagrama.
El eje X representa la distancia desde la
Tierra, el eje Y marca el paso del tiempo.
Según Terra, su trayectoria es
solo una línea vertical,
con una distancia igual a cero
y cada marca en la línea equivale
a otro año desde su punto de vista.
La trayectoria de Stella irá desde ese
origen hasta un punto a 11,5 años
a 10 años luz de Terra...
para luego converger a una distancia
cero dentro de 23 años.
Al paso del primer año,
Terra enviará una señal de luz desde
la Tierra hasta el cohete de Stella.
Ya que la luz tarda un año luz en viajar,
su trayectoria será
una diagonal de 45 grados.
Y como Stella se está alejando de ella,
cuando la luz la alcance,
habrán pasado 7 años para Terra
y más de 4 para Stella.
Cuando Stella vea
la segunda ráfaga de Terra,
ella ya estará en su viaje de vuelta.
Ahora, sin embargo, como viaja
hacia la fuente de la luz,
se tardará menos tiempo en alcanzarla,
y ella podrá ver las ráfagas
con más frecuencia.
Esto significa que Stella
ve envejecer lentamente a Terra
durante la primera mitad de su viaje
pero envejeciendo rápidamente a la vuelta.
A Stella, mientras tanto,
le parece que Terra, la estrella destino
y todo el universo se están
moviendo a su alrededor.
Y debido a la contracción de la longitud,
Stella nota que la distancia entre ellas
se reduce por un factor de 2.
Esto implica que cada tramo del viaje
llevará unos 6 años
desde el punto de vista de Stella.
Cuando mande la primera señal a la Tierra,
habrán transcurrido 2 años para Terra.
Stella enviará cuatro ráfagas de luz más
durante su viaje de ida,
cada una desde más lejos.
Cuando Terra observe la primera señal
del viaje de entrada de Stella,
para ella habrán pasado 21 años.
Durante el resto del regreso de Stella,
Terra recibirá múltiples
ráfagas de luz cada año.
Así, Terra observará que Stella envejece
lentamente un 90 % de sus 23 años aparte,
y que envejece rápidamente
un 10 % del tiempo.
Esta asimetría explica por qué la
la paradoja no es una paradoja de verdad.
Aunque cada gemela es testigo
de que el tiempo
se acelera y se ralentiza para ambas,
Stella lo ve parejo,
pero Terra ve envejecer a Stella
más despacio casi la mayoría del tiempo.
Esto cuadra con las observaciones
del viaje espacial de cada gemela,
tardó 23 años terrestres, aunque parece
haber durado 11,5 años a bordo del navío.
Cuando las gemelas se reencuentren,
Terra tendrá 43 años, y Stella tendrá 31.
Stella estaba equivocada
en pensar que tanto ella como Terra
serían observadoras inerciales iguales.
Para ser un observador inercial,
hay que mantener una velocidad
y dirección constantes
respecto al resto del universo.
Terra estuvo en reposo todo el tiempo,
así que su velocidad fue siempre cero.
Cuando Stella cambió de dirección
en su viaje de regreso,
entró en un sistema de referencia
diferente al del principio.
Terra y Stella ahora entienden mejor
cómo funciona el tiempo espacial.
Y como gemelas de once años de diferencia,
son un ejemplo perfecto
de la relatividad especial.